[словацькою] Мобільний телефон там є?
[словацькою] Не знаю, подивися.
[словацькою] Добре, почекай.
[словацькою] Я тобі подзвоню.
[словацькою] Ні-ні, я подивлюся.
Не дзвони, він тут.
[словацькою] Гаразд.
[словацькою] Я візьму ключі. Замкнеш?
[словацькою] Так, зачиню.
[словацькою] Давай цьом.
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
А чого ти ці шкарпетки одягаєш?
Пішли!
[Сторожниця,
Закарпаття]
[наспівує ритмічну мелодію]
Прекрасно, молодці!
[словацькою] Красиво!
[Сміються]
Що це таке? Пішли, робимо коло ще раз!
На-на-на-на-на-на....
Ви готові?
— Де твої?
— Ось!
Чекай, ті не підходять, це не по фен-шую.
[говорить нерозбірливо]
Не по фен-шую...
Мені жовті дай.
Чекай, на балконі маєш.
Так, всі взуті, всі одягнуті?
Діти, давайте!
Талай, в тебе ременя немає, труси хоч маєш?
— Так!
—  Слава Богу, бо я тобі свої дам!
Мама займається колективом
вже чотирнадцять років.
Ну і ніхто не думав, що вона так розкрутиться!
Ми виступали на День села, вдома, десь тут...
[Дарина Габор
Менеджерка ансамблю «Наша Файта»]
А потім вони пішло-пішло і ми почали їздити
закордон: Словаччина, Угорщина, Румунія.
Але як моя мама каже:
«Я займаюся цим не заради грошей,
але я займаюся...»
Вона говорить всім: «Кожна жінка бізнесмена
має займатися благодійністю».
[лунає словацька пісня]
Словаки на Закарпатті
поділяються на дві групи:
це словаки як автохтонне населення,
яке тут проживало завжди,
і друга частина — це словаки,
які приїхали сюди, на Закарпаття,
з території сьогоднішньої Словаччини
як майстри різної справи.
Я належу до тої родини, яка жила тут завжди.
Мама — не словачка, тільки батько був словак.
Але, напевно, це словацьке зернятко
проросло досить сильно в мені.
І я з дитинства мріяла вивчити
літературну словацьку мову,
оскільки у нас усі словаки розмовляють діалектом.
Коли я росла на території Закарпаття і взагалі,
в тодішньому Радянському союзі
не було жодної словацької школи.
Тому словаки зберігали свою мову
тільки завдяки тому, що розмовляли нею вдома.
І завдяки костелам, церкві, релігії.
Хоч і священників тоді кидали у в'язниці,
їх було дуже мало,
але люди самі збиралися на служби Божі
і правили службу без священника.
Такі служби називалися «сухі служби»,
бо без священника.
Без причастя...
Я пам'ятаю, як дитиною, мені було 10 років,
коли на літніх канікулах була у бабусі в Середньому,
то ходила на такі служби Божі.
[грає словацьке радіо]
Може, почекаєш тут?
Я тут не була років п'ять.
Це церква побудована 1724 року.
Одного разу її зруйнував землетрус,
потім вона згоріла.
При Радянському союзі тут був склад.
Коли розпався Радянский союз,
мій дідусь почав відновлювати церкву.
Вони писали листи,
щоб віддали будівлю знову під те призначення,
під яким воно має бути, — під церкву.
Тут минуло моє дитинство, тут було все  —
дискотеки, вечірки, шашлики.
У цій будівлі є спеціалізована
загальноосвітня школа
з поглибленим вивченням словацької мови.
Ну ми її коротко називаємо «словацька школа».
Після довготривалого ремонту,
після досить не простих перемовин,
укладання угод на міжурядовому рівні,
ось відкрили цю красиву будівлю.
Коли її відкривали, моя доця тоді
була у другому класі і вона казала:
«В мене буде школа, як у...»
Це вже емоціїї...
«Як замок у Гаррі Поттера!»
[сміється]
Так, добре, надягнемо маску.
Ми прийшли на закарпатську філію «Суспільного»,
і піднімаємося нагору, де є...
— Добрий день!
... де є редакції, які готують
програми мовами національних меншин:
угорською, румунською, німецькою, словацькою.
Є ще русинська, ромська і російська була.
— [словацькою] Всім привіт.
— [словацькою] Привіт.
[говорять нерозбірливо]
[словацькою] Буде, треба їй подзвонити.
Сумку повішай туди.
Радуга — це Шарівський регіон,
це все всередині вишивалося вручну.
Це я малювала кожен костюм олівчиком
і мами брали,
викладали так і пришивали повністю
всю задню частину.
Це ось один костюм словацький...
Це — другий, це той самийрегіон, але інший...
Цей більш такий загальний.
Цей — конкретно тільки 2-3 села,
а от у цьому танцюють шарівську польку.
Це саме словацький візерунок.
В Словаччині воно дорого коштує,
виходить 3-4 євро за метр.
Я — самоучка. Першу машинку ми купили,
це була історія:
мама купила нові тюлі на вікна, понесла до швеї,
щоб вона пришила тасьми і зробила боки.
І заплатила за пошив більше, ніж за тюлі.
Каже: «Усе, ми купуємо машинку».
Я мала трохи часу і передивлялася
ці словацькі костюми, який вони мали вигляд.
Часто є таке, що села поруч,
а костюми зовсім різні.
[словацькою] Там маємо короткі фрагменти,
де був орган.
[словацькою] Ну ось, знову.
[словацькою] Ну то там повернеш.
[словацькою] Чи тут чогось не вистачає...
Словацька редакція була створена ще 1996 року.
У базовому штабі було троє-четверо,
а тепер нас п'ятеро.
Мілан у нас був піонер у техніці,
він освоїв монтаж на комп'ютері, освоїв програми,
зйомки, щоб з камерою
працювати і вчив потрошку нас.
Я сюди прийшла зі школи.
[сміється]
Тож я вже мала маленький
педагогічний досвід,
і коли прийшла сюди, то зрозуміла,
що це — моє.
Працюємо для словацької спільноти,
показуємо, як вона живе, як зберігає традиції.
Словацька спільнота не така велика
і більш орієнтована на відродження
та збереження своїх традицій.
Тобто темами наших передач є
дійсно культура, традиції,
різні заходи і фестивалі або, наприклад, школа.
Дітки в школі знають і приходять...
Діти вже хочуть зніматися.
Ой, мене зніміть, мене!
Така черга хоче інтерв'ю давати,
а прийде до мікрофона і три слова скаже.
Більше не знає, що сказати,
але в черзі стоять по 20.
Кажу, що досить, нам більше інтерв'ю не треба,
деколи відбою від дітей немає.
[лунає словацька музика]
Всі перемішалися з українцями,
вона — словачка, він — українець.
А дітям так класно — два Різдва,
дві Паски, розумієш.
[сміється]
Вони не б'ються, мама з татом,
куди йдемо цього року на Паску, до якої мами.
Бо римо-католицькі йдуть до одної мами,
а греко-католицькі йдуть до другої.
З угорцями, словаками, українцями
немає такого, що ти не такий.
[грає словацька музика]
Добрий день!
[словацькою] Привіт, доню. Ти чого?
[словацькою] Прийшла за тобою,
як ми домовлялися, що прийду.
[словацькою] Ага, добре. А скільки маєш часу?
[словацькою] Годинку, думаю.
[словацькою] Годинку...
Бо ми йдемо скоро знімати. Хочеш з нами?
— [словацькою] Так, хочу.
— [словацькою] Добре. Сядь, посидь.
— [словацькою] Добре.
— [словацькою] Ще трошки тут помонтуємо.
Зараз з тим, що я також займаюся
написанням текстів в учнівському урядуванні,
мама десь мені допомагає.
А десь вона мені допомагає.
Але, коли вона почала, як-то кажуть,
показувати свої таланти,
що стосується журналістики, їй було десь три рочки.
Три! Вона в дитячій кімнаті одягла мою блузку,
яку я вдягала, коли йшла на ефір,
причесалася і головне — надягла буси, сіла і...
Як то ти казала по-словацьки?
[словацькою] А тепер слухайте всі,
хто це іще не почув.
[словацькою] Даринко, знаю, що ти любиш
подорожувати, і що ти вже багато країн об'їздила.
[словацькою] Так нам до матеріалу іще не вистачає,
щоби ти нам сказала, де ти була.
[словацькою] Ми були в Парижі.
[словацькою] У мами був День народження,
тож ми їй зробили такий подарунок, були в Диснейленді.
[словацькою] А коли ми поверталися,
так трошки були в Німеччині.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Оператори
Макс Салій (Завалля), Сергій Розов]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агенства США
з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]